let's bring in Tony Dungy the
hall-of-famer NBC football night in
America analyst and of course the former
head coach in the NFL is that a
desirable job Tony if it's open I think
it really could be you've got all you
need to win they have won their in the
past just not to be the right type of
person as you say you have to be able to
go in there and not want any of the
credit and not be mad if you get the
blame but just make sure you win and you
know Jimmy Johnson did that for a long
time and they were successful and other
guys have gone in there for shorter time
have been successful but I think you can
yeah I just worry that like it it feels
like Jerry gets more involved like he's
not getting less involved it feels like
he's more involved as the years go on
well they've done some pretty good
things it's just you know something is
missing there I can't quite put my
finger on it but they're close and
you've got a lot of resources doing I
would say this it's a lot better than
some other job I the reason why I wanted
to have you on is what's going on with
the Patriots it feels like people don't
want to hear the details they already
believe the Patriots cheated or you
believe that it's a which which on if
you're a patriot fan here I'm just
curious Tony what what could i film of
an opposing coach that could benefit me
because you're allowed to talk to your
quarterback in to his in his helmet
this isn't college where you're doing
these hand gestures on or holding up
placards on the sidelines so what
exactly could I get out of this yeah
this is much to do about nothing I'm not
sure why the Patriots would do that why
they would take eight minutes of someone
else's sideline but you're not going to
get anything that you can really use
everyone is talking now everyone has put
the cards up over their face so you
can't even lip read I'm not sure what
they would get that would benefit them
so to me it's yeah it's breaking the
room I don't know why they would do that
it could be very innocent it could be
just the Patriots trying to make you
think that they're doing something that
you have to change your sideline
procedures a little bit I don't know why
they would do it versus the Cincinnati
Bengals a one win
none of it makes sense but I really just
don't think there's much advantage to be
gained at all yeah but you know it's
still the Patriots and that's where you
know Belichick says hey I didn't know
anything about this and you know he kind
of lost me trust me Dan there's nothing
that goes on in that organization that
he doesn't know anything about I can
promise you that
I said the same thing Tony I just can't
imagine that they've got some you know
freelance film crew and they're doing
this for these features and he knows
nothing about that nothing happened
there that he knows nothing about what
do you think the NFL does in a situation
like this is a tough one because again
it really is a very minor problem if it
was anybody else but the Patriots they
would just say hey you know what this
you got to be careful and let's move
forward there's gonna be a lot of course
on both sides there's going to be pushed
from as you say that the Patriot lynch
mob that says hey we've got to punish
them and this is terrible I'm not sure I
would not want to be in the NFL position
I'm not sure what they're gonna do yeah
I think it feels like it's just gonna be
maybe a hefty fine maybe it's $100,000
here because their repeat offenders here
and even though they admitted hey we did
something sorry we did it we didn't know
we were doing it we didn't get anything
out of this and here's the other thing
that bothers me when somebody as well
why would they do that against the
Bengals oh so they would do that against
the Ravens but they wouldn't do that
against the Bengals is what you're
saying it's like no no you can't you
can't answer it that way oh we wouldn't
do it against the Bengals no it's I'm
not sure why and the explanation well
hey we're looking at our scouts trying
to show the job they do why are you then
focused eight minutes on the other
sideline why not focus eight minutes on
your scouts and what they're doing but
yeah the whole thing is bizarre I'm just
not sure what the NFL should do at this
point and as far as the Patriots product
on the field here Tony because you were
in battles there with them and it felt
like you know maybe you had them in a
down year it's a different team or maybe
they weren't as good but it still feels
like they're dangerous
but maybe I maybe it's just because I
trust Belichick and Brady historically
am I am i overhyping them are they
really not that great no let's go back
one year exactly one year they played
the Miami Dolphins and Ryan Fitzpatrick
ate the defense up and I think the
Dolphins won 34 33 and then the next
week they played the Steelers and Tom
Brady's group only scored 10 points they
lost two games in a row in December and
we said the same thing the sky was
falling and the Patriots have done and
six weeks later the Super Bowl champ
teams that know how to win teams that
have good coaching and and a quarterback
like Tom Brady you can't count them out
I don't like their offense right now I
don't know where the help is coming from
last year they had some guys who nicked
up a little bit and they came back but
they're gonna play special teams and
they're gonna play defense and they're
gonna play sound offense and run the
ball and they've got Tom Brady nobody's
gonna want to play them in the playoffs
I'm not saying they're gonna win the
Super Bowl
but they're not going to be an easy out
but if you're looking at the best team
in the AFC the Ravens oh but by far and
I think the Ravens that they played them
10 times and if they played them eight
times in Baltimore they'd beat them
seven times if they played them ten
they'd probably beat them eight overall
but in the playoffs it's at one time you
get a punt block you get something
happen to return you just have a day
where it's close scoring that's how they
can win so it you know I wouldn't bet on
the Patriots beating the Ravens but it
could happen again
and before I let you go you being a
defensive minded guy played defensive
back if I said come up with a game plan
for Lamar Jackson could you come up I
couldn't right now and I'll tell you
damn what's going to happen when I was
coaching we get all these college
coaching staffs in this thing that will
come visit us and hey we want to talk
about this and defending the passing
game and how do you guys do this
what kind of drills you run what you're
going to see is a lot of professional
defensive coaching stairs taking
displaying to college football they're
gonna go to Nick Saban and Alabama
they're going to go to tables we need
they're going to go in what do you do
with this read-option how do you defend
this because the NFL coaches don't know
this has been going on this offense we
see from Baltimore everybody runs it in
college football some teams stop it well
Alabama stops as well but nobody knows
how to deal with this in the NFL it's
gonna be a year to catch up the only
thing I was thinking and once again we
think we have a blueprint like Buffalo's
got the blueprint well Buffalo's got a
really good defense I still think if I
can make him throw outside the numbers
here then then I have a pretty good I
have a better chance with that I have to
be able to contain him running but if he
does throw I don't want him using the
middle of the field I want to see if he
can be accurate and have the arm
strength to throw it outside the numbers
there but I don't know who has that
ability to be able to do it unless it's
you know say someone like San Francisco
well that's the formula the two teams
that have played them the best that I've
seen have been Buffalo and Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh played him really threw a
couple of interceptions they pretty much
stopped in front him but these are teams
with great speed they played a lot of
zone and they crowded the middle of the
field Buffalo made one mistake they got
into man coverage and they got confused
they gave up the long touchdown pass on
a blown coverage but other than that
they played them pretty well and I think
that's what you have to do is you got to
have a lot of speed to to run him down
on those options and you've got to crowd
the middle of the field and make them
through to the wide receivers outside
the numbers but it's tough to do all
that because you got to use your
safeties in the run game you've got to
make sure you're aggressive tackling
they they put a lot of pressure on good
to visit with you Tony who do you guys
have on Sunday night we had Buffalo
against Pittsburgh should be great my
counting has done a great job
Sean McDermott has and two teams
fighting for the playoffs that I'm gonna
be excited to see great to talk to your
tone best to the family yep you too
Thank You bud that's Tony Dungy from
or Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]